>> Tucker: WELCOME TO "TUCKER
CARLSON TONIGHT."
OVER THE WEEKEND AMERICANS
GATHERED IN CHURCH AND
SYNAGOGUES TO PRAY FOR THE 11
INNOCENT PEOPLE WHO WERE
MURDERED IN PITTSBURGH ON
SATURDAY.
THEY BOWED THEIR HEADS AND ASKED
GOD FOR HEALING AND THOUGHT HARD
ABOUT HOW TO BRING THE COUNTRY
TOGETHER AND IMPROVE THEMSELVES
AND BE KINDER TO THE PEOPLE
AROUND THEM.
THAT IS THE AMERICA YOU GREW UP
IN.
A DESCENT PLACE FULL OF DECENT
PEOPLE TRYING TO DO THE RIGHT
THING.
THERE IS THE OTHER AMERICA OF
CABLE NEWS AND TWITTER.
POLITICAL OPERATIVES RUSH TO THE
SEEN OF HUMAN TRAGEDY TO
LEVERAGE IT FOR POLITICAL GAIN
AND MAKE SNAP JUDGES TO
IMPLICATE THEIR POLITICAL
OPPONENTS IN CRIMES THEY DID NOT
COMMIT.
THEY USE HERE AND RAGE TO
ACCOMPLISH WHAT REASONED
ARGUMENT COULD NEVER ACCOMPLISH.
THEY COMMIT MORAL BLACKMAIL.
THEIR AIM IS GUN CONTROL.
A CRAZY PERSON COMMITTED AN EVIL
ACT SO YOU MUST BE DISARMED.
THIS TIME THAT'S NOT THEIR GOAL.
THEIR GOAL IS MORE
COMPREHENSIVE.
THEY WANT TO TAKE CHARGE OF WHAT
YOU ARE ALLOWED TO SAY AND
THINK.
HOW?
BY BLAMING YOU AND YOUR OPINIONS
FOR THE CRIME.
WATCH.
>> THE FANS OF HATRED WERE
FANNED BY A PRESIDENT WHO KEPT
TALKING ABOUT THIS CARAVAN OF
REFUGEES AS IF THEY WERE
TERRORISTS OR COMING TO COMMIT
ATROCIOUS CRIMES IN OUR COUNTRY
WHICH THEY ARE NOT.
>> Tucker: THE MESSAGE WAS NOT
SUBTLE.
THE MURDERER WAS ANGRY ABOUT
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS.
IF YOU ARE OPPOSE ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS, YOU ARE LIKE THE
MURDERER.
YOUR VIEWS INSPIRE OTHERS TO
KILL.
YOU ARE IMPLICATED IN THIS
ATROCITY.
YOU ARE A MONSTER JUST LIKE THE
LUNATIC IN PITTSBURGH.
YOU MUST CHANGE YOUR BELIEFS.
OTHERWISE, YOU WILL BE PUNISHED.
THIS IS HOW FREE SPEECH DIES AND
FREE THOUGHT.
THE RANGE OF ACCEPTABLE OPINION
MIMICS THE CNN SCRIPT.
THERE IS NO DISAGREEMENT.
THERE IS ONLY CONFORMITY.
CHIRPING THE PARTY LINE.
THAT'S THE GOAL.
AFTER A CENTURY OF DEFENDING
FREE SPEECH, THE LEFT IS NOW ITS
ENEMY.
LAST WEEK THE SOUTHERN POVERTY
LAW CENTER ISSUED A LIST OF
DEMANDS FOR TECH COMPANIES.
ANYONE WHO DISAGREES WITH THEM
MUST BE PREVENTED FROM OPERATING
A WEBSITE OR RAISING MONEY ON
LINE OR ORGANIZING EVENTS OR
EXPRESSING THEIR OPINIONS.
THAT'S AN ORDER THEY SAID.
THE SOUTHERN COMFORT LAW CENTER
HAS NO MORAL STANDING TO MAKE
ANY OF THOSE DEMANDS.
YET, THE LEAST VIRTUOUS ARE THE
MOST SELF-RIGHTEOUS.
WATCH HOWARD DEAN EXPLAIN THAT
AMERICAN POLITICS IS NO LONGER
ABOUT POLITICS, ABOUT COMPETING
IDEAS.
INSTEAD POLITICS IS A SPIRITUAL
BATTLE BETWEEN LIGHT AND DARK,
GOD AND SATAN HIM.
>> IT'S GOOD VERSUS EVIL AND THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
IS EVIL.
>> Tucker: EVIL.
THAT'S NOT THE LANGUAGE OF
AMERICAN CIVIC LIVE.
IT NEVER HAS BEEN.
THAT'S THE LANGUAGE OF HOLY WAR.
EVIL PEOPLE CAN'T BE REASONED
WITH.
THEY SHOULD NOT BE LISTENED TO.
THEY MUST BE CRUSHED AND
DESTROYED.
DID HOWARD DEAN REALLY MEAN
THAT?
WE WILL ASSUME FOR THE SAKE OF
THIS COUNTRY HE DIDN'T MEAN THAT
AND NONE OF THE OTHER PEOPLE
TALKING LIKE HOWARD DEAN MEAN IT
EITHER.
WE HOPE ALL HAVE LOST THEIR
SENSES AND WILL WAKE UP FEELING
ASHAMED AND READY TO REJOIN THE
ADULT CONVERSATION IN PROGRESS.
THAT'S OUR HOPE.
EITHER WAY, WE DO NOT PLAN TO
STOP TALKING NO MATTER WHAT THEY
DEMAND.
EVERY AMERICAN HAS AN ABSOLUTE
RIGHT TO EXPRESS HIS VIEWS
REGARDLESS OF WHAT TWITTER
THINKS.
WE ARE NOT GIVING IT UP ON THIS
SHOW.
YOU ARE ALWAYS FREE TO SAY WHAT
YOU BELIEVE EVEN IF WE DISAGREE
WITH YOU.
FREE EXPRESSION DOESN'T CAUSE
EXTREMISM, IT SOLVES IT.
PROFESSOR HANSON, DO YOU THINK
THAT SPEECH IS AT STAKE IN OUR
CURRENT DEBATE?
>> I THINK IT IS IN A WAY.
ALL OF US WANT A SAFE SPACE TO
USE THAT LEFT WING TERM.
WE DON'T WANT TO TURN ON THE
TELEVISION FOR NBA AND BE
LECTURED AT.
WE DON'T WANT TO SPEND
THANKSGIVING LIKE IT'S 1861.
WE WANT IT TO TONE DOWN, BUT WE
DON'T KNOW WHAT THE RULINGS ARE.
WE ESTABLISHED THAT JAMES DOES
NOT SHOOT STEVE SCALISE BECAUSE
OF WHAT BIDEN OR MADONNA SAID.
IT WASN'T JUST WHAT THE
OPPONENTS OF DONALD TRUMP SAID.
WITH THE LATEST 2 INCIDENTS WITH
THE PIPE BOMBS AND IN SAYOC AND
THE SYNAGOGUE SHOOTINGS, WE ARE
TOLD IT'S DONALD TRUMP BUT WE
DON'T KNOW ABOUT THE CAUSE AND
EFFECT.
WE DON'T KNOW IF HE WAS TOO PRO,
OR ANTI-ISRAEL.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE THINK I
DON'T LIKE HATE SPEECH, BUT I
DON'T KNOW WHAT THE RULES ARE.
IT LOOKS LIKE IT'S A LEFT WING
RING OF TERROR.
THESE SELF-APPOINTED FACEBOOK
PEOPLE CAN GIO TEEN YOU.
WHAT ARE THE RULES OF SPEECH?
WHAT WE HAVE SEEN ON FACEBOOK
AND TWITTER AND youTUBE THE
MASTERS OF THE UNIVERSE LACK THE
MORALITY TO TELL US WHAT IS
ACCEPTABLE SPEECH.
IF WE GO BACK TO THE SERMON ON
THE MOUNT AND SAY LET'S TREAT
PEOPLE THE WAY WE WOULD LIKE TO
BE TREATED.
TELL THAT TO HILLARY CLINTON.
WHEN MITT ROMNEY LOST IN 2012,
HE DIDN'T SAY I WON'T BE CIVIL
UNTIL THE NEXT ELECTION.
WHEN GEORGE BUSH WAS OUT OF
OFFICE IN 2009 HE DID NOT GO
ACROSS THE COUNTRY AS OBAMA IS
NOW CALLING THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES A LIAR.
THEY DON'T THE MORAL HIGH
GROUND.
>> Tucker: THEY DON'T HAVE THE
MORAL AUTHORITY TO DECIDE WHO
SPEAKS.
I WONDER IF THEIR ASSUMPTION IS
RIGHT.
ARE CERTAIN IDEAS SO BAD THAT
THEY CAUSE VIOLENCE?
I WONDER IF IT'S POSSIBLE FOR
ANY SOCIETY TO SQUELCH IDEAS.
NOT JUST LEFT AND RIGHT BUT A
HUMAN PHENOMENON.
IF YOU PREVENT PEOPLE FROM
HAVING THOUGHTS DON'T YOU CREATE
EXTREMISM?
>> YES, THAT'S AN AGE-OLD
DILEMMA.
WE DON'T WANT THE MEDICINE TO BE
WORSE THAN THE DISEASE OF
SENORSHIP THAT TELL US WHO CAN
SAY WHAT.
WE ERROR ON THE SIDE OF FREE
SPEECH.
THE PEOPLE WHO WANT TO CENSOR
FREE SPEECH DON'T WANT TO DO IS
SYMMETRICALLY.
PEOPLE ARE VERY, VERY ANGRY AND
ALIENATED.
>> Tucker: ANY TIME YOU HAVE
WHAT IS A RELIGIOUS CONVERSATION
THAT BEGINS WITH, I AM A GOOD
PERSON AND YOU ARE NOT, HOW YOU
CAN SOLVE ANYTHING?
IF ONE SIDE BELIEVES ITSELF TO
BE SAVED AND THE OTHER DAMNED?
>> YOU CAN'T.
YOU HAVE TO BE EMPIRICAL.
YOU HAVE TO SAY THIS PARTICULAR
ACT IN THIS PERSON'S MIND
OCCURRED BECAUSE THIS PERSON
SAID SOMETHING.
NOBODY HAS BEEN ABLE TO MAKE
THAT CAUSE AND EFFECT.
IN A NANO-SECOND HALF EDUCATED
PEOPLE GET ON AND SAY I ACCUSE
YOU OF ALL OF THIS.
EVERYBODY IS AFRAID.
YOU AND I ARE ONE NANO-SECOND
AWAY FROM HAVING YOUR HEAD